[Music]
Jessica come down you're the next
contestant on do the saying everyone's
favorite game show where you rub me
until something awesome happens you
playing do the thing okay let's dialogue
we all agree there's a lot of toxic
masculinity at this school right
birthday boy destroy your property holy
[ __ ] wanna [ __ ] everyone I've got to put
a delay on these protests the boys all
made lists of the hottest girls in the
gray and the girls are [ __ ] pissed
I'm sick of the voice objectifying yeah
I feel like a dirty piece of meat like a
slab a prime red that nose was wide yeah
I can't go back to school and when
people ask how was your spring break I
say Oh spine I had incest I don't know I
think the word is cute
oh no it's trying to breastfeed ooh it's
got a strong latch I think it's all the
extra teeth
Parkin missus gonna wreak havoc do you
really wanna go home you like you just
the way you are
I am pansexual holy [ __ ] I'm just trying
to be an ally to women
[Music]
mcdhh Andrew and Jessie virgins until
college [ __ ] me
sophomore year are we doing this week
well we're working with coach Steve what
is your current grooming situation
sweetie I call it the bride okay cuz
it's one brush I use for all my parts my
head my teeth my painter pinna in my
[ __ ] Jesus in my vagina
that poor brush
[Music]